foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
dystrophin quantification in
pre-clinical and clinical settings
I am Shelley Mulock of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar has been
organized by biotechnie using the lab
Roots platform during the presentation
you will hear about the use of simple
Western the fully automated Western
blotting instrument that provides
quantitative protein measurements using
as little as three micro early layers of
sample in just three hours you may have
also heard of simple Western as the
capillary Western unlike traditional
Western blooding simple Western does not
have a gel to block transfer step making
the technique more reproducible
especially when analyzing larger
proteins such as dystrophin in addition
to being much faster than a traditional
Western blot simple Western is more
sensitive has a larger dynamic range and
uses less sample recently simple Western
was recommended for dystrophin
quantification in the industry guidance
submitted by the pair project muscular
dystrophy to the FDA
to learn more about simple Western and
other solutions from biotechnic please
visit their their website at
bio-technique.com
as a reminder today's webinar is
educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education icon
on the far left of your screen to obtain
your credit credits
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also if you
experience any technical
difficulties you can utilize the QA box
and we will assist you directly
I'd like to now cordially welcome
today's speaker Dr Anna Meek artzmurus
professor of translational genetics at
Leyden University Medical Center Dr Arts
Marez aims to bridge the gap the Gap
excuse me between stakeholders involved
in drug development for rare diseases
and to develop Exon skipping therapies
for patients with unique mutations she
has budget published over 230
peer-reviewed papers 11 book chapters
and 15 patents and has given many
invited lectures at scientific
conferences and patent organization
meetings
Dr Arts arrest has received numerous
awards for her contributions to the
muscular dystrophy field and we are
excited to have Dr Arts Mirage share her
insights with us today welcome Dr arts
for us the floor is yours
thank you very much for the kind
introduction and a opportunity to
present here about dystrophin my
favorite protein
um before we go into the nitty-gritty my
disclosure I'll give you the executive
summary
my Institute has patterns on exoskipping
technology and as a co-inventor I'm
entitled to share royalties
um and anything else that I do lectures
advisory
Consulting all the remuneration for that
goes to lumc and maybe specifically for
this webinar I was not instructed or
paid by uh protein simple people to
present in any way on the way so all
statements are my own um and and I've
not been instructed to make specific
statements
um this the talk will focus on as I
mentioned already my favorite protein
dystrophin
and we really learned what this person
did by seeing what happens when patients
don't have dystrophin and and the the
dystrophy Gene is located on the X
chromosome and that means that mainly
boys are affected because they have only
one X chromosome so if that is mutated
they don't have a backup or females
generally have a functional copy and and
therefore generally are carriers and
don't have symptoms in rare cases also
females will have symptoms but will
focus mainly on the the 99.99 of the
patients who are male and and lacking
dystrophin patients suffer from
Progressive loss of muscle
tissue and muscle function and you can
see here different stations and you can
see them from young to old and the very
top left patients you don't really see
anything yet there but already the
second picture you can see that when
this boy gets up from the floor he he
uses the garage manure so he uses his
hands to get up from the floor and that
is due to muscle weakness and then you
can see that patients have lower doses
so they have these weird stems because
several muscles are are deteriorating
but not all at the same time so what
patients try to do is with the limited
muscle capacity that they still have
left to keep the the as much function as
they can patients generally lose the
ability to walk but before the age of 12
then also lose their arm and hand
function and you can see again that
patients use whatever way they can to
remain maintain the ability to for
instance self-feed but around the age of
20 patients rely
all help of others for most daily
activities including assisted
ventilation so the disease is very
severe and sadly most patients die in
the second to Fourth decade of Life due
to the lack of dystrophy
so what does dystrophin do in healthy
individuals it connects the cytoskeleton
of muscle fibers to the connective
tissue that surround each muscle fibers
and also connect each muscle fiber to
each other
um and it has several domains so at the
end terminal the beginning of the
protein there's two active binding
domains that bind to the cytoskeleton
and at the end of the protein there's
The distroglycan Binding domain that
connects to The extracellular Matrix and
extracellular Matrix proteins and what
you can see is that in the middle
there's 24 Spectrum like repeats and
four hinge regions so what's interesting
about this thing is that the two crucial
domains are located at the beginning and
the end of the protein
now so what this person does IT
stabilizes muscle fibers during
contraction and if there's no dystrophin
then during each contraction damage will
occur so that's chronic continuous
damage that leads to chronic
inflammation Scar Tissue formation
impaired regeneration and the gradual
loss of muscle tissue and muscle
function that I just described for the
patients so at a molecular genetic level
what goes wrong is that patients have
mutations that disrupt the reading frame
um and you see an example here so you
see that the genetic code x048 250 is
missing and you see also that 47 doesn't
fit to x151 so what happens then is that
you're in the wrong reading frame so the
wrong amino acid will be translated and
often uh an early stop will will happen
these dystrophins are not functional
because only the beginning of the
protein is is is correctly produced and
this Linker function to the external
Matrix is lost and this leads to the
severe to Shared Muscular Dystrophy and
of course what you can then ask yourself
so what would happen if the reading
frame the genetic code would be
maintained and I have an example here
Exon 48 to 51 51 are missing so the
deletion is larger however you can see
on on the graph 47 feet to 52. so what
happens here is that protein translation
can continue from start to end
and normally proteins would not be
functional If part of the the domains
are are missing however because the
crucial domains for dystrophin are
located at the beginning and the end and
in the middle you have 24 different
repeats while lacking a few of these
repeats is not that much of a problem
these proteins are still partially
functional how do we know they're
partially functional because they're
found in Becker Muscular Dystrophy and
this is a less severely less severely
progressive muscle wasting disease so
the aid of onset is later and the
progression is slower
um So based on this we know that if you
have no dystrophin at all you have a
severe duchenne if you have an
internally deleted Dystrophy and you
have the less severe better Muscular
Dystrophy and I don't want to trivialize
Becca because it's still a severe
progressive muscle wasting disease but
if you're coming from Vegeta and angle
then it is the less severe disease
um what's interesting for Becker muscle
dystrophy is that the dystrophin levels
do not correlate with disease severity
so not all Becker patients make the same
dystrophy depending on where they have
their infrarmentation they can make
different dystrophins and what we know
is that if you look in a group of Becker
bases that all have the same in-frame
mutation
then the discipline levels don't
influence the disease severity so
whether you have 20 or 80 of the same
dystrophin that doesn't correlate with
severity there's other factors that do
but we don't really know them we know
that it's not dystrophy levels what does
influence disease severity is where the
infraim mutation is located and that
makes sense because you need specific
parts of the dystrophin so there's
in-frame mutations that leads to
duchenne when the the domain connecting
to the extracellular Matrix is missing
or when all three x and binding domains
are missing then these dystrophins are
not functional even if the mutation is
in frame however most record patients
have a deletion that either is located
in a green domain so in the central rot
domain where we know there is redundancy
or at the beginning in the the two
acting binding domains and you can see
there's a third acting binding domain
located in the middle of the central
domain so if there's two missing then
the third one can still result in a
partially functional protein but better
bases with mutations at the beginning of
the protein have a more severe phenotype
so this is an interesting aspect of the
dystrophyll protein now going back to
this Yen the more severe end of the of
the dystrophinopathy spectrum given that
it's caused by a lack of dystrophin of
course restoring dystrophin would be
anticipated to slow down all the
pathological processes like the impaired
regeneration the fibrosis formation the
muscle wasting so there's work ongoing
on trying to restore this and this is
gene therapy trial so trying to add a
copy of the the gene that's not
functional actual skipping
um
and genome editing and team therapy is
in clinical trials excellent skipping is
approved in in the U.S and Japan and so
called on retro is approved in the the
EU but not in the US and genome editing
is still in pre-clinical stage but for
all these things the goal is to restore
dystrophin and what's important to bear
in mind is that except for the the stop
code read through these approaches do
not restore full-like dystrophin so
they're all based on this reading frame
rule where in-free mutations leads to
Becca and outer frame rotations lead to
the Shell but exoskipping microdistroxin
and genome editing so the gene therapy
and the genome editing none of them
restores fully functional dystrophyll
and this is of course important to bear
in mind
um when you do your clinical trial and
what therapeutic effects can you expect
bearing in mind that these dystrophins
are not fully functional but only
partially functional
now briefly go over the different uh uh
um dystrophin restoring approaches
starting with gene therapy so with gene
therapy you're trying to provide a copy
of the genetic code that is disrupted
and in case of this year and you want to
provide a copy of the dystrophy Gene
however if you want to read skeletal
muscle you need the adeno-associated
virus the aav virus and AV is a very
small virus this is why it can infect
skeletal muscle but because it's small
the complete dystrophin code genetic
code does not fit and not even the
smallest Becker disruption that we know
fits so we had to to model that we had
to do a minimalistic design and try to
develop these micro dystrophin that
really compare the bare necessities the
actin binding domains at the beginning
the domain at the at the end that
connects to the distroglycan and the
extracellular Matrix and then you can
see three flavors of my that are
currently in clinical trials and they
either have four or five spectrums like
repeats domain and two or three hinges
and so these are very short they're
shorter than the shortest Becker protein
that we know however they're engineered
you can see at the bottom you see the
different Spectrum repeats well they
form these shapes and of course you can
imagine if you make a transgene you can
make sure that these shapes fit together
nicely if you're doing Excel skipping or
if you have Becca or if you do genome
editing then you you end up with
whatever the reading frame the restored
reading frame provides you with and
that's not always a properly faced
Spectrum repeat domain
now how does Excel skipping work Excel
skipping tries to restore the genetic
code RNA level so the gene is
transcribed and then you have the axons
coding for the protein you have the
influence not coding for the proteins
and during splicing all the axles are
linked together if we're back to our
example where X1 48250 is missing we
know now from the backup base and then
the deletion of action 48 to 51 would be
in frame so what we try to do during the
splicing process where all these
Excellence are linked together is to
hide one of the axons from the splicing
machinery now how can we do that we can
do this with small modified pieces of
RNA called antisense oligonucleotides
and that's bind specifically to the
Target exome hide it from the splicing
Machinery splicing Machinery looks for
the next available axle but in this case
is Exon 52 this is then connected to in
this case 47 the reading frame is
restored and the audition patient can
make a Becca type protein and to bear in
mind these aons don't have the eternal
life the restore transcript don't have
the eternal life the better like
dystrophin don't have the eternal life
so this is a treatment that has to be
repeated and the currently approved
compound rely on weekly intravenous
injection of these alns the advantage of
the aoms is that they're very small so
you can do systemic delivery and you
don't need an aav to deliver them
however weekly intravenous infusion is
of course a burden so people are also
working on genome editing I mentioned
already this is in a free clinical stage
but it uses the same trick just
targeting the DNA here we have a
deletion of exo52 just to underline that
not everyone has the same deletion but
you can see a deletion of x152 you can
also restore the reading frame here by
skipping episode 51 and when you want to
skip episode 51 on CNA level you can use
a guide RNA to cut at the acceptor
supply side of this exome that is then
repaired but after Double stranded break
and normal homologous and joining the
repair will introduce errors and due to
these errors the splice acceptor side of
action 51 is now mutated so Exon 51 is
no longer recognized by the splicing
machinery and every time a transcript is
now made from this DNA the splicing will
have the restored reading frame and a
Becca type distribution can be made the
challenge with genome editing is that
you need a genome editing tools to
deliver to skeletal muscle so you need
the the guide RNA to tell the the cas9
where to cut a unit cas9 to actually do
the cut and for now the only option to
deliver this is aav
so still in free clinical State
um so each of these approaches tries to
restore dystrophin and most of them
tries to restore a becca-like dystrophin
and of course because you try to restore
this person for each of them measuring
dystrophin is important and what's even
more important how do you measure this
and of course the a tools question how
much dystrophin do you need and that
will be the focus of the rest of my
presentation and for those of you who
were hoping to get a metric number how
much dystrophin do you need to get a
metric number
um well spoiler you will not get a magic
number because the problem is that how
much dystrophy you need depends on
different parameters so and these are
the parameters that I will discuss so
that hopefully you understand why it's
not like you need eight percent of
dystrophy or you need 15 it's impossible
to give this this percentage because of
different things now go over them one by
one starting with the distribution of
expression
um
because when we say when I say for
instance 10 dystrophin what do I mean 10
dystrophin can mean that 10 of the
muscle fibers make 100 of dystrophin or
it can mean that all muscle fibers are
each making 10 dystrophin or anything in
between
um so how do you measure this and what
do you measure well ideally you use a
combination so you can use the Western
blocks or the West system to measure the
size of dystrophin and the amount the
Western world is competitive but you
also have to use immune fluorescence
because you want to know if you see 10
of Dystrophy and you want to know how is
this distributed to all fibers make a
little bit do a few fibers make a lot
um n is the distance properly located at
the fiber membrane and the downside side
of the immune fluorescent is that the
the computation is relative so you get a
relative intensity so you need a western
block because that will sell it will be
more accurate to Accurate with with
regards to
quantification but also will tell you
the size I won't go into the mass
spectrometry because that just gives you
the amount of dystrophin and I think you
then still need the Western block to see
the size and you need to immune
fluorescence to get all the other things
so
what I say is if you want to measure
dystrophin you want to have both you
want to have the Western block but you
also want to see how is it distributed
now before showing some pictures of what
it looks like
um a configuration because if you want
to measure dystrophin in skeletal muscle
you need a muscle biopsy and muscle
biopsy are invasive and I show you here
a publication that we did a couple of
years ago collaborating with patient
with the patient Community to see what
is the impact of a muscle biopsy on
patients and families and and well if
you want to read more then you really
have to to go into the paper and read
everything but showing you we hear some
of the the biopsy scars and you can
imagine that this makes patients
self-conscious
um it's it's not a simple thing these
are really big scars and and large
amounts of muscle are removed and
patients and families understand why
this is needed but of course
um it is invasive and especially knowing
that patient have very poor regeneration
they lose a little bit of the the
limited amount of muscle that they have
anyway
um what's interesting to mention is that
families and patients accept the
biopsies but they especially accept them
in the early stages when it's open label
proof of concept as soon as it becomes a
placebo-controlled clinical trials they
are less willing to undergo the biopsy
because there's a risk that they have
the biopsy and they are implico and then
later maybe in an open label they will
switch to drug but then that often would
involve even an additional biopsy and of
course that's that's one more
so another thing that's important to
bear in mind is that most patients make
some dystrophin and when I started in
the duchenne field in 2000 it was clear
two Champions has made no dystrophin and
Becker made some Dystrophy and healthy
individuals made 100 of dystrophin what
we know now that we have more
sophisticated techniques is that almost
all duchenne patients make some
dystrophin and in by immune fluorescence
and this is a picture from a
collaborators that presents a biomarin
and this picture really nicely shows
that there's two types of dystrophin
that patients make you can see that all
the different fibers show a little bit
of green so there's trade amounts of
dystrophin probably because there's very
low level alternative splicing that
corrects the reading frame you also see
these reverting fibers that are very
brightly stained these are fibers that
probably have erosion from secondary
mutation in the satellite cells in the
secondary mutation if they restore the
reading frame then of course those
satellite cells can now produce high
amounts of dystrophin after they've
contributed to muscle repair
so both reverting fibers and Trace
mounts occur how much varies for
individual patients so this means that
it's not the question of one biopsy
post-treatment you also all
you always also need a baseline biopsy
and that makes it more invasive because
you need at least two biopsies
um to to see whether there's an increase
in dystrophin expression after treatment
um so I already uh mentioned it
um and I think for now people do the
open biopsy getting the scarves that I
just showed you and because if you do a
needle biopsy that's less invasive
there's too little muscle tissue to do a
robust immune fluorescent and Western
blotting and of course the the West may
offer a solution there because you need
much less input
um showing some examples from clinical
trials and pre-clinical trials and from
from our own work so this was a clinical
trial that took place in 2006 there was
no West system then so the regular
Western block was done and this was a
local treatment so local intramuscular
proof of concept we did this only one
for Action 51 skipping and after that
everything was was done systemically but
this was really the first in man
and therefore the local treatment was
was done and then a biopsy was taken one
month after treatment
um and for your reference on the top
right the healthy controls on the bottom
right this Yen and then after treatment
you really see that dystrophin is
restored it eats off before patients
that were included in this trial but you
also see if you look for instance at
patient three
um you see there's areas where there's
no distance in and these are the areas
where there's a lot of fibrosis and you
don't expect dystrophy to be restored
there because fibrotic tissue doesn't
Express dystrophin transcript but this
is something to bear in mind and we'll
get back to that as well
um so on the top here you see the
relative quantifications of how many
fibers are destruction positives what
was the relative expression but this is
immune fluorescent so that's not very
quantitative on the bottom you see the
Western block this was the hand cast
Western blotting system
um not very competitive but it confirmed
that dystrophin was restored and of
course now we have more sophisticated
systems to measure this uh but this
really was the first proof of concept
that dystrophin could be restored after
exoscaping
um so these are some dystrophyll levels
um from our animal models our
pre-clinical studies in in the MDX miles
and I'm showing you this picture to
really outline how low the amount of
Dystrophy and are that we sometimes have
so less than one percent around two
percent and that's really if you do the
hand costs Western blocks it's difficult
because what we can measure we can see
that there's there's dystrophin while in
the MDX usually before treatment we
don't see any dystrophin so we can see
that there's dystrophin but it's really
difficult whether it's one percent one
point five point five Etc that is very
difficult and you can see the error bars
here and so also some some West examples
so this is the uh dilution series that
you can see um in a wild type Mouse and
then also on the next slide
um the tree that might where we get much
more robustly detect these very small uh
amounts of dystrophin and also what you
can see and so for whatever reason and
don't ask me because I don't know why
but for whatever reason the dystrophin
size in the west system is always around
200 and something kilo Dalton why of
course we know it's for 127
um in real life but we're sure that this
is the dystrophy because this is the
band that disappears
um both in Mouse and human in patients
um compared to the healthy control so
it's the right band it's just for
whatever reason uh it it gives the wrong
size
so
we see that the distribution will
influence
um how what the distance restoration is
like and already you can see well 10 can
mean different things but another
consideration is that different patients
will have different dystrophins after
the treatment
um
we've already discussed the difference
between the microdistrofin and the
dystrophys that you get after
exoskipping and genome editing
um the distal fins after actual skipping
and genome editing are often dystrophins
where we know that they're functional
because we see them in backer patients
so literally patients are walking around
with these dystrophins for the micro
dystrophins
um that's not the case
these are only induced in patients so
far and so we we still have to see how
functional they are however if we look
at Excel skipping the dystrophin levels
that are produced are very low that are
in the order of one percent while with
micro dystrophin the amount that we
produce are much higher
and so you have to see which domains are
present and also this phasing of the
repeat that I mentioned already with the
micro dystrophing you can tailor you can
engineer that repeat one and two and for
instance uh 23 24. they fit nicely with
genome editing and echoescaping you rely
on what is in frame and it's possible
that these repeats don't fit properly
for instance you'll have the first
thirds of repeat one connected
um to the last fourth of repeat two and
then that may not be as functional as
when you have proper facing
um what we know is that this
functionality is more of an issue in
heart than it is in skeletal muscle so
there's some dystrophins that seem to be
very functional skeletal muscle but
where Becca patients have primarily
cardiomyopathy
um so then
the dystrophin amount that that patients
produce so how much do they produce
amends already for Becker patients
um it doesn't matter whether you have 20
or 80 percent however for the same
patients the dystrophin amount that
we're storing now and exoskipping we're
still in a linear range where more is
expected to be better so we know there's
a certain threshold where it doesn't
matter that you have more or less but
below the threshold more dystrophin will
be more functional and that's the phase
which part we're in with Excel skipping
at the moment so
to answer the question so how much
distruction do you need and how much do
you need for what we use a trick of
random action activation and I mentioned
already the dystrophy Gene is located on
the X chromosome so female carriers will
have 50 of dystrophyll because in half
their cells the the the healthy
um dystrophy chromosome is active and in
half their cells that the mutated
chromosome is active this excellent
activation takes place when the cells
are in about a 100 cell stage so in the
embryo and then each cell individually
determines whether to inactivate the X
chromosome from the father or the mother
but that pattern is then inherited by
each of the Mother cell daughter cells
so we know 50 is enough uh most carriers
do not have symptoms but when you use a
model that has cute action Activation so
that preferentially inactivated what you
can do is crossing this
execute excellent activation model with
normal dystrophin to an ndx Mouse if you
do that the carriers will preferentially
inactivate the chromosome that has the
normal copy of dystrophin so they will
have lower amounts of dystrophin and how
much that will differ for each of the
different mice
um so we've done this and again this was
before we had the West system
um and we we did uh we did this in the
regular MDX miles we did this in the
double knockout Mouse with this more
severely affected we did several uh
studies and literally we've had to do
Western blotting with handcuffed yells
in hundreds of different uh for hundreds
of different samples also doing uh uh
duplicates or triple cuts and so
um again this was really a lot of work
and um well the people involved
tell me that if they've had the the West
system then they would have been a lot
happier
um
and they said it's not not me
so then I mentioned already we we did
this well you can do this in the regular
mbx Mouse model and this is what we did
but we also did it in a mouse that also
lacks eutrophin and mice that don't have
different and eutrophin are very
severely affected they generally die
before the age of 12. and
and so this was a model where we could
see well what what's the impact of low
levels of dystrophin also on survival
and what we did what we saw when we
looked at this mice and we didn't know
the amount of Dystrophy and when we
looked at demise we had to look at it
afterwards so after animals were were
sacrificed then we could look how much
Distortion they were making so what you
see at 10 weeks old
um we have the mouse on the left looking
okay the mouse on the right looking okay
at 14 weeks of age you can see that the
mouse on the right starts to develop
kyphosis so it has this little hump in
the 23 weeks it's more prominent and you
can also see the muscle weakness so when
you uh pick up the mice by still
normally it has a reflex where it
spreads the legs you can see the mouse
on the right is less able to do that due
to muscle weakness we had to sacrifice
the mouse on the right
um due to Rema Humane reasons that we
pre-specified
the mouse on the left live beyond the
air and in the end we had to sacrifice
it because it got age-related
cancers and so it never developed a
dystrophenopathy
so
I mentioned already so we can we can
only see how much dystrophy in the mice
had after they died and what we did we
compared the good miles without any
dystrophin and no euprofin and I
mentioned these mice die off before 12
weeks of age we had one super Survivor
that lived for five months so if we look
at the five months so the latest time
point that any of the the double
knockout mice were still alive we see
that even the mice that made less than
five percent dystrophin
about 70 percent is still alive
and every older mice have made more than
five percent dystrophin all of them are
still alive at five weeks and if we then
look at 10 months we see that now the
mice that have less than five percent
dystrophin they start dying
um there's they're significantly longer
list than the ones without any
dystrophin but they do start dying but
some are still alive and a few optimized
between five and fifteen percent started
dying but those having more than 15 all
were still alive
we also looked at function and the dark
blue is the mice without any dystrophin
the Orange is mice that I have 100
distraction control mice and and then
the the light blue is mice that have
more than five percent and the dark blue
is say the middle blue is mice that have
less than five percent
and what you can see is that having some
dystrophin improves function not back to
normal but clearly more than mice that
have no dystrophin at all and whether
you have more or less than five percent
doesn't really seem to matter here
um so what we also know is it used to be
the case that people say you need 20
dystrophin what we know now that is not
the case we have seen better patients
now with Western block and West system
uh Quantified that have less than 10
percent dystrophin we've also seen that
duchenne patients that make really low
amounts of dystrophin that we couldn't
pick up 10 plus years ago because we
didn't have sophisticated techniques we
can now pick up that they have really
low amounts of dystrophin order of one
percent they have the slower disease
progression so our later loss of
ambulation and also if you look at six
minute walk tests North Star functional
output and we see that they have a
slower disease progression so what this
all tells us is that a little bit can go
a long way however all these models and
these patients have distribution from
birth in patients you intervene later in
the same patients they have no
dystrophin or very little dystrophin and
then you start the treatment and that's
of course a different case
um so what we did we also did aom
treatment
so exoskipping treatment in our double
knockout mice
um at very low doses so again we're
storing about one to two percent of
dystrophin and what you can see is that
the models the mice treated with the a1s
have a significantly extended survival
and they're not back to normal but the
order of magnitude
um I mean it's clear that there is a
treatment effect
um even with these very low dystrophin
restoration
so finally the time of intervention
matters and I was working up to this
already a little bit
um if we treat earlier there will be
more Target tissue there's less fibrosis
yet so there's more tissue that
expresses dystrophin where you can have
dystrophin restoration and also I mean
even if you would be able to restore
dystrophin in fibrosis
um I mean the the the tissue doesn't
Express this person if you would force
the expression then suddenly the
fibrosis would not go back to being
muscle so one muscle tissue is lost it's
irreversibly lost and probably for each
muscle there's this point of no return
even if we restore dystrophin the damage
is done and you will lose that function
so the bottom line the earlier you treat
the larger the therapeutic effect is
expected to be
um finally something about excellent
skipping I mentioned already there's
four exoskipping drugs approved at the
moment it's a mutation specific approach
and you really restore very low levels
of dystrophin with these approaches and
what still needs to be done is to show
functional effects
due to these low levels of dystrophin
and there's an applicability a
bottleneck and that's more clear in this
slide so
Echo 51 skipping applies to 14 of
patients so if you have
um uh if you want to do your clinical
trial this is still possible I mean it's
a rare disease but 14 of patients for
one of the most common rare diseases
that is still doable but then you see
that the numbers go down quickly so nine
percent for 45 8 for 53 and then for
instance if you look at at 50 and 43
uh it's it's four and three percent so
that makes doing these clinical trials
really challenging and another challenge
is that well there's now these drugs are
proof but it's clear that there's room
for improvement so at the moment for 51
skipping for instance it's not just the
confirmatory studies that are ongoing to
show that indeed this approved compound
is effective there's also new and
improved aons for x151 skipping that are
tested in parallel in clinical trials
and then suddenly you have your 14 but
you have to divide it in really small
groups
so the challenge is
um once we start doing this we're more
and more and more exons at some point it
won't be possible to show in a large
group that there's a slower disease
progression because there's simply not
enough patients so what we really need
to do as a field is to establish the
correlation and knowing that you need
this amount of dystrophin and then we
know that down the line there will be a
functional effect because then this
different restoration would be a good
circuit marker and also for these
smaller groups where you have maybe 10
or 20 patients worldwide and this is the
case for exoskipping but maybe the same
will apply in the future for genome
editing
so in summary
um there's many aspects that influence
how much dystrophy needed to have
therapeutic effects into sham patients
and it's really important to measure
Dystrophy and restoration approaches in
clinical trials to confirm Target
engagement to confirm that the the
approach works as a plan but also
pre-clinically if you want to improve on
exoskipping to see well this was our
reference compound this is the improved
do we indeed see in increase and likely
for the more rare mutation distance and
restoration
um
assessment will be even more important
because then showing function will be
much more difficult due to the small
group size and finally I would like to
thank all the funders that have funded
us throughout the years and also the
group um and I I
um made the the people that were really
heavily involved in some of the work
that I showed you here I made the the
the the their names both
um but also thanking our collaborators
at the the the Department of Neurology
because they obtained samples from from
vision and Becker patients for further
studying and the people at present a
biomeran who really did a lot of work in
optimizing and standardizing the
Dystrophy and quantification processes
so I thank you very much for your
attention and I'm happy to answer
questions uh in the time that is left
all right thank you Dr Arts Moross for
your informative presentation and we
will now start the live q a portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
okay so it looks like we do have some
questions coming in
um the first question that I see is how
does delivery such as localization to
skeletal muscle versus other tissues
affect the potency of the treatment
strategies that you described
well I think the um it's skeletal muscle
is one of the most difficult issues to
reach
um first because muscle is very abundant
so about 30 to 40 percent of our body is
muscle and then it's not you're not
treating one big organ you're treating
muscles that are well distributed over
700 larger and smaller muscles
throughout the body
um and then the muscle has really dense
endothelium so it's really difficult to
to reach and I think that is how the AAC
viral vectors manages to to deliver to
to skeletal muscle but bear in mind uh
the the brunt of what you inject goes to
liver
and the same goes for the exoskipping
compound
they go to to muscle a little bit but a
lot uh goes to kidney and is also
cleared by other urine so I think that
is that the challenge is that muscle is
a challenging tissue to deliver
okay thank you so much for that
um our second question is what
challenges remain with respect to
quantifying dystrophin
um I think well
I think the the the challenge is that we
have our dystrophin restoring
approaches but they they restore very
low levels of dystrophin so to
sensitively and robustly measure these
really low amounts of dystrophin that is
a challenge
um and of course what we can say so we
need better techniques but I think the
bottom line is we need better drugs
because we need to to restore higher
amounts of dystrophin because then also
there would be more of a therapeutic
effect and I think ideally we would want
to be able to measure distribution do we
want to measure everything at once like
seeing the location seeing the uh the um
the abundance seeing uh the size I don't
think that is possible with current
techniques but I think if you use both a
western or Philip Western and the
the the immune fluorescence then you can
you can know what you need to know and I
think I mentioned already
um if the the open biopsy could be
replaced by a needle biopsy that would
also be a big Improvement because that's
a lot less invasive however
um it's really important to make sure
that if you do a biopsy that biopsy can
be used so patients prefer to have an
open biopsy then having a needle biopsy
that then is is not usable for for
analysis
uh that makes a lot of sense thank you
for that
um okay the next question is where is
the industry evolving the fastest and
what advancements do you envision having
the largest near-term impact on the
field of muscular dystrophy research
so I think currently what's
[Music]
what is to improve the delivery of excel
skipping compounds or whatever compounds
to muscle and so that can be
um better uptake of aaves to muscle so
we can use lower doses that are less
toxic or better uptake of the exoskip
and compound by by muscle I think if we
would manage that that would well
benefit not just duchenne but the whole
muscular dystrophy field and I know
there's a lot of research on going there
for instance conjugating antibodies to
oligonucleotides and and for optimizing
the the
the gene therapy approaches
um so that is uh I think that is where
most of the work is now and if people
manage to achieve that then that will
have an impact on on the whole muscular
dystrophy fields yeah absolutely okay
um thank you our next question is do the
Trace Amounts vary by uh myonuclear
domain as you move through
cross-sections
um so I don't really know whether the
trace amount is very I don't think we
really looked into that we do see I mean
per
myofiber you see that there's different
intensity if you will of the dystrophin
and also even across the myofiber
there's different intensities so I think
the answer there would be yes and what
we also did with our action activation
model of course we had some of these
mice that had about five percent
dystrophin expression we looked
longitudally and then you really see
very nicely the myonuclear domain
um because you see that around the the
nucleus that apparently can express
dystrophin you see dystrophin
restoration but you also see that it's
very limited and I think there was a
recent paper in in pnas about the
myonuclear domain that really showed
that dystrophin does not travel far from
its nucleus sadly okay yes all right
thank you um the next question is uh how
do we quantify micro dystrophin or a
mini dystrophin using WB do we have
specific antibodies or the uh for these
or do we need to use dystrophin antibody
itself yeah so while both is possible um
because of the size you know the size of
the micro dystrophony you know the size
of mini dystrophin so because you notice
if you use the c-dermal antibody
um and well of course the c-terminal
domain will always be in this micro or
mini dystrophins because it's crucial
for connection to the extracellular
Matrix if you use that antibody you will
see your micro dystrophin so you can use
that and I know that for some of the
micro dystrophin the companies are
trying to make say the micro dystrophin
specific antibody that specifically
binds to well a unique domain like
Spectrum
repeat normal two into Spectrum repeat
number 16 that's not present in in
regular
um dystrophin but this present in the
micro dystrophin they're trying to make
the micro dystrophin specific antibodies
um but it's not really needed because
the c-terminal antibody will work as
well and especially with the micro
dystrophin and the meaning of dystrophy
you know exactly the size that they
should be
um and you probably have your plasmids
that you you you use to make your your
mini and micro dystrophing constructs
you can also use that um production from
that as a as a reference if you need to
okay wonderful that's very helpful thank
you
um our next question is uh well you're
being thanked for a wonderful
presentation I agree uh when do you
think a better treatment can be
available for for patients
so so I would like to say soon but I
think what what what I've learned from
well being in the field now for 23 years
is that
um doing clinical research and
pre-clinical research is difficult and I
think what we've shown now is that the
trick works we can restore these these
dystrophins
um but it needs to be better and then
trying to make things better generally
uses new approaches that have not been
tested before in humans and then we
don't know whether they will work in
humans and we don't know whether they
will be saving humans we've seen already
a couple of of approaches that looked
really promising in mice and then in
humans either they were not effective or
they were toxic so
um we really will have to wait for the
results of the clinical trials and with
each clinical trials yeah there's a
chance that it works but there's also a
chance that it doesn't work
um so I don't want to to make any
predictions because the yeah well it
it's not under my control if it was
under my control it would be really soon
but certainly it's it's not we have to
wait for the the results of the trials
and to see how how these compounds these
new compounds behave
yeah that makes a lot of sense thank you
um all right looks like we have one time
for one more question today so uh the
last question is uh what about
dystrophin Restoration in the diet uh
diaphragm muscle that is usually poorly
translated by aav is the threshold of
dystrophin different to restore its
function than for skeletal muscle or the
heart
so I don't think the threshold will be
different I think the challenge is that
um it's generally more severely affected
um so that means that so maybe you will
restore five percent dystrophin and
diaphragm but if 50 of the diaphragm is
already fibropic for instance and then
that five percent is less than if you
have a muscle that's completely healthy
um so I think that that will probably
play a role um but also there we will
have to wait and see and I think what's
also good to bear in mind because people
focus a lot on the diaphragm but you
don't only breathe with your diaphragm
your intercoastal muscle also help you
to to to breathe so hopefully these are
better preserved and they can also help
with with improving respiratory function
or slowing down respiratory function
um but yeah again also here I I I'm
speculating now and I don't have a magic
number for you to to say how much you
would need there
that's very helpful thank you so much
again Dr asmrs for your time today and
for your important research uh do you
have any final comments for the audience
today
no well if they if they come up with any
question I'm sure they can uh Google
Sherlock my my uh email address that
they're free to to email me any
questions that that they come up with
later that usually what happens to me is
that I need some time to process and
then I come up with questions so feel
free to to ask me questions via email if
you have any questions and I hope that
the the talk was useful for people oh
absolutely and thank you again Dr asmas
we really appreciate it uh we'd also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
biotechnic for underwriting today's
educational webcast if interested please
visit
bio-technic.com to learn more about how
simple Western provides quantitative
protein measurements in a reproducible
and fully automated format improving
your data quality from as little as
three microliters of sample in just
three hours before we go I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab Roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's Live Events until
next time take care everybody and
goodbye